[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZOLTAN ARATO: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Zoltan Arato.
I'm a product manager
of Google Cloud IoT.
Let me also introduce my
co-presenters for today--
Kerry Maletsky and Lucio di
Jasio, both from Microchip.
All right.
IoT Security-- Solving
the Primary Hurdle
to IoT Deployment.
In this breakout
session, we are going
to show you evidence why
connective product companies
and IoT fleet operators find
security a top challenge.
We will also talk about how and
why these challenges ultimately
come down to a question
of cost and complexity.
And most importantly, we
will show you a toolset
or give you a toolset--
an end-to-end toolset-- that
can help you solving these
challenges.
So let's take a
look at our agenda.
First, very quickly, we
will touch up on the why--
why the need is undeniable,
why it's a top concern.
Then we are going to talk about
the theory, the principles
of solving IoT security.
And probably the longest
part of the presentation
is about the solution proposed
by Google and Microchip.
So let's start by this number.
This is an actual
Gartner number,
so this is not an estimation.
And this is from last year--
number of connected devices--
so it's probably more now.
I guess all of you
remember those estimations
from a few years back
predicting super-high numbers
of connected devices.
Now this is real.
This is happening, our devices
generating more data than ever,
and that also means
that the attacks
surface is growing rapidly.
And important to highlight
that these devices are, most
of the time,
resource constrained,
and security
measurements are close
to nonexistent many times.
And there is evidence to that.
So we see a clear
acceleration of attacks.
Probably the most
well known is Mirai.
I'm sure many of you
have heard about Mirai.
It was a botnet
attack two years ago.
It hit low-security cameras--
CCTV cameras-- and
performed a DDoS attack
against [INAUDIBLE],, one
of the biggest domain name
services in the US and
brought the internet down,
or most of the internet
down, for multiple hours.
Just another example,
which happened this year--
a hacker got into a casino using
a thermostat of a fish tank.
So not only DDoS attacks
are a threat in relation
to IoT deployments,
but also, these devices
are connected to
your network, so they
can access their network.
So if a hacker can
get to your device,
they can go into your network.
What this really means to us is
that IoT security is complex.
It's challenging.
It takes time to secure
an IoT deployment,
and it's not something you can
do once your fleet is deployed.
It cannot be an afterthought.
You really need to
take care of security
before you deploy devices.
So let's take a look at the
challenges of IoT security.
This is just a summary.
We are going more into
the details very soon.
So strong device identity
and authentication,
how you identify
your devices, how you
authenticate them, how you
use asymmetric keys for these,
securing the manufacturing
line, how you transfer keys--
it's a complex process.
How you protect
your keys and how
you make sure that
the software ran
by your device is what
it is supposed to run--
and key rotation-- how to
treat keys as ephemeral
and how to update
keys as needed.
And of course, application
layer security--
it's very important,
but we are not
going to talk about
application layer security.
We are going to focus on
the IoT-related parts.
It's not that it's not easy--
or it's not that it's easy, but
it's much more well-described
or discussed, so we are not
going to talk about that here.
Even though most
of these principles
can be implemented
using software only,
a much higher level
of security can
be achieved if we involve
specialized hardware.
So that's why hardware plays
a key role in secure IoT
deployments, and that's also
why we partnered with Microchip,
because they're offering
plays a key part in what we
offer as a secure solution
for end-to-end deployment.
So I would like to invite
Kerry on stage, who
will talk more about Microchip.
KERRY MALETSKY: So I
don't know how many of you
are familiar with Microchip.
We've been around
for 30 years, and we
ship over $2 billion
8-bit MCUs every year,
so maybe many of
you out there have
designed some kind of
system, whether PIC or an AVR
microcontroller, and you're
familiar with Microchip.
You may or may not be
familiar with the broader
range of products that Microchip
has, among other things
like wireless and wired
connectivity solutions
and analog devices, interface
chips, and security devices.
So all in all, that
kind of gives us
this idea of having devices
that are smart like an MCU,
connected wireless,
which is really
what IoT is all
about, and secure,
which we're going to
make the case here
is a key part of how you
build an IoT endpoint--
thinking about security
at a hardware level.
And obviously, Microchip
has a good solution
across that board.
So let me just start and kind
of reiterate some of the points
that Zoltan made.
It's hard to overestimate
the importance of a device
identity, right?
When you get past all the
three- and four-letter acronyms,
you get all the words.
Everybody is all happy about
what they got in security.
You have an identity
at an endpoint.
It's a number.
That's really all it is, right?
There's a number.
It's a digital world.
If that number gets
compromised, then you
don't have a secure endpoint.
Doesn't matter what
protocol you use.
algorithm you use.
If I can copy your number,
your device ID, your key,
whatever you want to call
it, then I am you, all right?
So everything we're going to
think about is going to be,
how do we take that ultimate
route of trust out of device
key and protect that
in a way that then we
can build upon that to
build a secure system?
And so to do that, you
need a couple of things.
You need to be able to
verify that identity.
And obviously, if I just
send you my identity
and send over the
network, I'm Kerry.
Well, everybody
knows that, right?
You can look that up,
so that's not really
a very good identity.
Needs to be something that
can be verified without being
disclosed, trustable, unique.
Obviously, it's not good
if there's a lot of Kerrys
out there, and
there probably are.
So there must be something
different about me
than the others.
We'll talk about that.
This isn't to talk
about cryptography,
but let's just say that
asymmetric cryptography
is a good solution
for this approach.
Maybe we'll store a
private key as an identity.
We'll use the public key
as a way to validate that.
I won't talk too much about
how the mechanics of it work,
but you'll see how that plays
out as we go forward here.
So OK, we got this number, this
digital ID, this private key,
whatever you want to call it.
I said that's what
everything is about.
That's what's important.
Well, how do you get it
in your gadget, right?
How do you put that private key
into your device in such a way
that, well, ideally,
not too many devices
have copies of the same
private key when you mess up.
You've got a diverse
manufacturer environment.
Maybe you've got subcontractors
on three continents.
Maybe one guy builds
one part of the system.
Another guy builds another
part of the system.
Maybe next year you have a
different subcontinent than
you've got this year.
How do you manage that
environment in such a way
that the way these
identities go in your device
can really be trusted?
They're all unique.
So this is a pretty
complicated problem,
and let me propose a
solution that says,
I don't care where
you manufacture.
Let's move that identity
process, that identity
assignment process,
out of the manufacturer
sub-cons into the supplier
of the semiconductor.
So you build a--
take a secure element,
secure chip, same thing,
and the manufacturer of the
secure chip-- in this case,
Microchip-- we program
that identity in it.
So when it shows up at
the manufacturing sites,
at your subcontractors, it's
already got that identity.
And let's go one step
further than that.
Let's build not
only the identity,
but the relationship between
that identity and something
else.
That relationship might be
manifested in a certificate.
That's a traditional PKI scheme.
It might be manifested in some
kind of a registration scheme.
That's what we'll talk
about a little bit later
in the presentation.
So identity and a relationship
prebuilt into that chip
so that no matter where
you build it in the world,
you get that same
trust of, it's unique.
Nobody was watching when
you put it in the device.
OK, so we got an identity.
We got a way to get
it in your gadget.
But wait a minute.
Then the gadget's going
to go out in the field.
There's going to be jillions
of these things, right?
You guys are all big,
successful companies.
You're going to sell millions
and millions and billions
of devices, and everywhere
around the world,
there's going to be your device.
And because you're so
successful, a lot of people
are going to want to try
and copy your device.
And if they want to
copy your device,
they need to get that digital
ID out of one of them,
and then make 50 copies of that
one or maybe get out of 100.
So you really don't want them
taking the digital ID out
of your device, and you've
got to protect against that.
One way you do that, or maybe
the only way to do that,
is to provide some
kind of secure storage
for that private
key, that secret.
And let's just say that you
really don't want anybody
to mess with it.
They can't copy it.
They can't change it.
They can't delete it.
Any of those things
are really bad.
Once that happens,
then the device
really doesn't have a connection
anymore to the network, right?
So that's good, but
it's not enough.
You got to protect
what your device does.
I got the temperature sensor.
I've identified that
it's in room 12.
But if I can change
the software,
well, yeah, I'm talking
to the thing in room 12,
but no, it's not really
give me the temperature.
It's giving me a
bogus number, right?
So you've got to
protect the firmware.
There's lots of ways to do that.
Let's just say one
fairly traditional way
is to verify a signature over
that code every time the thing
boots, right?
So it's hard to
change the software.
I have to replace the
chip without getting
the thing to reboot.
So let's verify a code
signature at boot.
A lot of people call
that secure boot.
That seems like a good answer.
We'll connect that a little
bit later to hardware security.
Now, Zoltan made a mention
about key rotation.
And you might say to
me, whoa, whoa, whoa,
you just said you're
going to store
this thing really super-secure.
Nobody's going to
be able to touch it.
Why do I need to rotate it?
Hey, nobody can mess with it.
Well, there could be
rules, regulations,
policies that demand it.
That's OK, all right?
We've all got rules
we've got to follow.
Sometimes they don't
make any sense.
That's just life.
So there could be policies.
There could be limits.
Every algorithm has
a limit on the number
of times it can be used before
the key is no longer considered
to be valid.
So that's OK.
I don't mind that.
So you want to be able
to do this rotation,
but at the same
time, you can't think
that rotation is a substitute
for security, right?
If I say, well, I don't need
to secure the key [INAUDIBLE]
because next week, I'm going to
have a new key, so who cares?
It's only one week.
That isn't going to work, right?
Because the bad guys
are going to find it
not next week, not next day.
They're going find it three
seconds after you rotate
that key, and if
you don't have a way
to protect that key for
that week, that year,
that month, that 10
million transactions,
then you still
don't have security.
So key rotation is
important-- got to do it--
but it's no substitute for
an environment in which you
didn't have to do it.
So think about that.
There's lots of ways to do that.
I'm not going to talk
about it too much.
PKI or asymmetric cryptography
gives you a couple of ways.
You can either generate
new keys and sign them
with a trusted key.
You can use a
derivation mechanism.
There are lots out
there that are good.
You could store multiple
keys in your device.
You could ship it with 10
keys, and we could say,
I'm going to use the keys
[? that ?] [? ran, ?]
or it's got a
10-year life cycle.
I'm going to use the first
key for the first year
and the second key
for the second year,
however you want to do it.
That's fine.
It's all good.
And the cloud is going to
manage those policies, right?
So the cloud understands
the trust relationship.
The cloud understands the
architecture of the device,
and the cloud can say, OK, hey,
I don't like that key anymore.
Let's go on to the
next key, right?
So that's the good thing about
having the cloud relationship.
No longer does the device
have to be able to say, hey,
I don't like this key anymore.
Now the cloud can manage that.
So Zoltan touched on this.
You build your system.
You got all kinds of software.
You love all your
software solutions.
You got this stack.
You got that stack.
Maybe you downloaded
some software.
But at the end of
the day, there's
that thing that I started
with, that digital ID, right?
It's got to be used.
You got to put it as input to
some complicated algorithm,
and that means the software
has got to touch that.
So there's a piece
of software that
has access to that digital
ID, that private key.
So if one piece of
software can touch it,
how are you going to prevent
other pieces of software
from touching it?
Oh, you got an OS.
You got kernel code.
Yeah, sure.
We all know all kinds of
exploits which allow things
that you wish wouldn't touch
stuff to actually touch them.
So especially in
the IoT world, where
you've got these
complicated things,
you got all these stacks doing
all these different things,
but you're a temperature
sensor, right?
What's the temperature
in room 12?
But it's really complicated
to do that, right?
So what we're going
to propose here
is I'm going to isolate
those private keys from all
of the software.
I'm going to say no software
can touch the private keys.
I don't care what
software you have.
Good, bad, big,
small, purple, green--
doesn't touch the private key.
And by doing that, it
leaves a lot of questions,
a lot of problems
you have to validate.
It takes those away, right?
And by the way, it's not
that we don't like users.
It's not that we
don't trust them.
It's that they make
poor choices, right?
OK, how many of us
have ever logged on
and created a password
that may not have been
an optimal password, right?
Once?
Twice?
It happens, right?
So you can't really trust users.
It doesn't mean
they're bad people.
they're untrustworthy.
It just means that they
make choices that may not
be consistent with security.
So you're not going to
let a user see it, not
let its software see it.
And when we talk
about hardware, you
might think, oh, I've
got a microprocessor.
That's a piece of
hardware, right?
No, not really.
Microprocessors are
typically not designed
to protect keys in a way that
an aggressive attack might
get them, and I'll show
you in a minute what
an aggressive attack means.
And if you think about it, if
you connect all these dots,
now, that means that it's also
protected in the manufacturing
phase, because even the
manufacturer doesn't have a way
to attack it, right?
So you've got some sub-con
soldering chips on the board.
Doesn't matter.
He could be just as
untrusted as some guy
out in the field who hacked the
sensor off the wall of room 12,
right?
So totally protected during
the manufacturing phase.
So OK, that's nice.
These are all nice concepts.
Now, how do we build
that into something
that's useful that we
can ship to customers
that connect to the cloud
and do a useful thing?
It's got to have value, right?
So first thing,
use a secure chip.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit here about the ATECC608A.
So I won't say that
too much, you know?
Think of it as a
secure element, OK?
It's a secure chip.
Think of it as an
electronic safe.
What's it going to do?
It's going to do--
of course, it's going to
store that digital ID, right?
It's got some secure
[? W probably. ?]
It's going to put
the key in there.
It's just a key, right?
It's just a number.
Going to store that
there, and it's
going to include enough
crypto engines on it
so it can act on that
key without having
to divulge the key.
It wouldn't be very interesting
if I had to send the key out,
right?
The key never, ever
leaves the chip.
You want to do an
authorization, you
want to do some
kind of validation,
you say, OK, hey, prove
that you have that secret
without divulging the secret.
And so all of that's done
inside this boundary.
So there's a hardware boundary.
You try and get through the
boundary as an attacker,
and you can't, all right?
So it's all encapsulated.
There's no software inside.
It's not something
where you write the code
and maybe there's
some bugs in the code.
It's all a turnkey solution.
And I'll just point out
the red box over there.
I like to point this
out because everybody
thinks, well, random numbers.
I don't know.
Just get some keystrokes.
It doesn't matter, right?
Well, actually, every single
cryptographic protocol
out there, one way or the
other, requires random numbers,
and random numbers are
really hard to generate.
So my favorite definition
of a random number--
one that's never been
generated before and will never
be generated again, right?
That's a random number.
It's maybe not a
technical description,
but it's not a bad
functional description,
and it's really hard to do that
in a way that you can trust,
right?
Everybody's got their
multi-gigahertz, multi-core
processor.
Think how many times it
can try different numbers.
So if you want a number
that's different this time
than last time, it had
better be really good,
and it's really hard to do that.
So I'm going to put all
those things inside this box.
And that means you hae a
simple interface to it, right?
I-squared-C, one wire,
so easy to talk to,
but hard to get inside.
So that's the basic concept
of a secure element.
OK, I got this.
What good is it?
Because it's all
by itself, right?
That's not the temperature
sensor in room 12.
That's just a little box
with a device ID in it.
How are you going to use it?
Well, you're going to
connect it to whatever
you've got on your system.
So you've got some kind
of processing element.
Maybe it's the Edge TPU
that just got announced.
Maybe it's an MCU,
an MPU, and that guy
is going to talk to it.
Now, the slide here
shows something
like where the MCU passes
a challenge to the chip.
The chip responds
with a response,
and the MCU has some
way of verifying that.
That's a fine answer.
Well, we're actually
going to show later
in the presentation in the
demo is the cloud sending
a challenge down through the
microprocessor to the chip.
The chip responds,
sends that response back
through the microprocessor,
up to the cloud,
and then then cloud
decides whether it's
going to accept this
transaction, this relationship
or not, right?
So I said at the beginning
that asymmetric cryptography
and private keys make a nice
way to think about a device ID.
I stand by that.
It's beautiful, but there
are downsides to PKI,
and some people like symmetric
or shared identification
as well.
I'm totally cool with that.
That's a good idea.
There's a time and
a place for that.
So that challenge
and response-- it
could be a challenge in a
signature if it's asymmetric.
It could be a challenge in
a Mac if it's symmetric.
Those are perfectly
valid things,
and I would never say that one
is more secure than the other.
One may be more
appropriate than the other,
but they're both secure
ways to accomplish
this problem of verifiable
identification, right?
And then, let me just make a
small point for those of you
out there who have designed
PC boards and the like.
This is a tiny,
little thing, right?
It's not your video
processor with 300 I/Os.
It's a tiny, little box with
a couple of wires for I/O.
And when Lucio does
his demonstration,
you'll see it's probably the
smallest chip on the board,
even though it has the
most security of all
those chips on the board.
So OK, we're going to think
about this secure element now.
It fits whatever your
endpoint looks like.
I don't care whether it's
got a 32-bit, 64-bit, 8-core
processor, or it's an 8-bit,
single-threaded machine
with K bytes of memory.
Doesn't matter.
And everything in between--
you can put this on that
board, and now you've
got a route of
trust that you can
trust separate from
all your software,
from all the other
pieces of your system.
So key protection-- great.
I'm up here.
I'm selling this thing.
I say, hey, it's really
strong with the keys.
Trust me, right?
Well, maybe you don't.
So how is it that people
get these keys out, right?
I mean, lots of
software attacks--
Zoltan's slide showed a bunch
of different software attacks.
But you know, if you're
making a billion gadgets,
you've got a lot--
somebody else would like
to steal your market, right?
10% or 1% of your billion
gadget market is a big number.
I'd really like to
have that as a bad guy.
And so I'm not going to stop at
some published attack, right?
I'm going to do all sorts
of crazy things, like--
this particular crazy thing I
got up there is a micro-prober.
You could scrape the
top off the chip.
You could put some
needles down on the chip.
And trust me, this is
not a complicated thing.
You can buy
micro-probers on eBay.
You can use them
in your kitchen.
It doesn't really require
anything too complicated.
Really, you just
kind of probe down.
You know that JTAG lock that
you got on your processor?
You hit that bit, and
no more JTAG, right?
Unless I put a micro-probe
down on that JTAG wire
and I pull it high and say,
oh, now I do have JTAG,
and I reuse JTAG to
read the key out, right?
So if you get a secure element--
there's a picture of it,
a piece and a blow-up
of a piece of that.
Secure elements typically
will have a shield.
So that serpentine thing on the
side covers the entire chip.
There's nothing to look
at, and the signals
that are going through
that have nothing to do
with cryptographic or identity.
They're just random
signals that we check,
and if you short
them out or cut them,
then the chip stops
working and it's dead.
Look, I'm only showing
this particular attack
because it really
looks good on a slide.
Well, there's pictures,
shields, stuff like that.
There are way better
attacks than this one.
This one's
complicated, you know?
Probably, people
are going to notice
if you take your thing apart
and strip the silicon off.
My favorite non-visible
attack is some kind
of a side channel attack.
You put a resistor in
series with the battery.
You do single trace or
maybe multiple traces
of the power signature during
a cryptographic operation.
You take that trace away and you
put the battery cover back on.
Hang the thing back on the wall.
And now, at your leisure,
you analyze that trace.
And using that analysis,
you can find the key.
And so if you think that
anybody's microprocessor won't
leak data when it's
executing code--
this isn't the right
slide presentation,
but I got some really good
ones to show you how it's done.
It's actually not that hard.
So there are hundreds
of different attacks,
and you have to defend
against every one, right?
Because of course
the attacker is only
going to do the weakest link.
Whatever one thing you
didn't defend against,
that's what the
attacker is going to do,
and it won't matter that you
defended against the other 99.
So you need to have
a way to protect
these secrets that defends
against everything, right?
Attacks you've never heard of--
and so that's probably not
going to happen by default.
It's going to happen
because somebody
has spent careers and teams
working on just that problem.
And so that's what a
secure element does, right?
The whole point of using
a secure element like this
is that that's all we
do every day is think
about how the bad guys are going
to try and get the secrets out.
We don't know anything about
temperature sensors, really.
All we know about is that bad
guys are going to try and get
the secret out of our chip.
We don't want to
let that happen.
OK, so let's build that
up now into an IoT thing.
So this is sort of how
IoT devices look, right?
You've got some
application, your IP,
the thing that makes
your device special.
You got some sort of
cloud connectivity stack,
ideally connectivity
to Google Cloud, right?
Because everybody wants the
cloud, and without the cloud,
how are you going to
get to your device?
What good is it?
You've got some sort
of operating system.
Maybe it's a real-time
operating system, maybe not.
You've got some big
processing element
that's running
your communication
stack and your security
stack, in this case looking
at something like
TCP/IP and TLS.
They're common things.
There are other ways to do it.
And then you've got some
radios, some wireless hardware,
and some sensors
to do your thing.
That's kind of how
things-- that's
how an IoT device looks, right?
That's how it's done.
But let's think about
it for a minute.
In the world,
there's a big variety
of architectures and cost
points and power points
for embedded systems.
You've got-- everybody
is holding up
the red one in the top, right?
You've got some big,
multi-core processor
with gigabytes and fancy
OSes, and that's great.
There's a place and
a time for that.
I wouldn't want anything
less in my pocket.
But that might not be the right
answer for the temperature
sensor in room 23.
Maybe you want something
that's a little bit lower cost.
So you could think
about something
in the middle, some kind
of RTOS sort of thing,
maybe a little bit more
restricted operating
system, maybe a real-time
operating system.
That's a good thing.
Millions of those
units are sold a year,
but you know, you really like
Zoltan's slide about that 8.4
billion and that curve.
You want to be on the
billions of sides.
You want to sell
billions of devices.
If you're going to do
that, and if you're
going to consume that data, if
you're going to think about,
how do I manage the heating
and cooling in a building
with 1,000 rooms?
I need 1,000 temperature
sensors, right?
If I want to manage some kind
of a factory with 1,000 valves,
I need to know each
one of those valves.
I need to control them, right?
So now we want to think
about these billions of units
where you want to power
them with 8-bit processors.
And so AVR and PIC
microprocessors are probably
the kind of processors
you're going to use.
They're the number one
and number two processors
in the market.
But these are very
resource-constrained things.
Don't think gigabytes of memory.
Think Kbytes of memory.
And don't think how many--
how big is the power
supply going to be?
Think, can I make that
battery last for five years
without replacing it?
All right, so we're talking
about a totally different
environment here, and this
is the thing that drives
that 8.4 billion number, right?
It's this constrained
environment.
So how do I simplify the
development of an IoT device
so that I can build
those small devices
and I can get them to
market in a timely manner?
Because the other guy is trying
to build the same thing, right?
If I don't get there sooner,
he's going to take my market.
So let's redraw that picture
a little bit differently.
You still got your
application software.
Whatever makes you special,
you still got to do that.
You got some kind of
cloud connectivity stacks,
but now let's reduce that
to the component pieces
necessary to talk to a stack.
Here's the component
pieces for Google Cloud.
And beyond that, now we're
going to really start
to change things.
We're going to say, OK, I want
a development environment where
I can automatically
generate the drivers I need,
because really, I only care
about the stuff in yellow
or orange or whatever
that color is up there.
I only care about what's my IP.
I want to push the
button, one click,
and get all that
other stuff done.
And at the lowest level, I
want to split the security
and communication stacks
away from my processor.
I want to focus on writing the
software in my process, my MCU,
that does what's
important to me--
processes that
temperature, right?
It was the number-- not that
complicated, in a sense.
And I'm going to leave
the security stack.
I'm going to put it
in a secure element.
I'm going to take the
connectivity stack,
I'm going to go put it
in a wireless element.
And now I'm going to build a
much simpler and more secure
IoT element.
And I'm going to get to
market faster because I'm
going to do it with
much less software
and in a development environment
where I can push a button
and get it done, right?
And that's what we're all about.
So just so you don't
think this is vaporware.
I mean, it's a good concept.
But if we can't
reduce it to practice,
then that's not so interesting.
So Lucio's going to show a
demonstration later where
we connect these four things.
The demonstration happens
to use this particular AVR
microcontroller, but this
concept, this architecture,
this software works with
any one of the thousands
of microcontrollers that
we and other people sell.
What we offer is a one click
software development approach.
So doesn't matter which
of the processors you use.
You push that button,
you get the software
stack necessary to do it.
The secure element that
we've been talking about here
implements all the algorithms,
whether it's symmetric,
whether it's asymmetric
to do that cryptography,
secure that key, and to
isolate your software stack
from all the cryptography.
So for instance, I
talked about secure boot,
validating your code image.
Well, that secure element
can validate the signature.
So instead of you have
thousands of bytes
and maybe minutes of
code execution time,
you push that hard stuff
off to the cryptoprocessor,
it does that software stack.
Same for Wi-Fi.
This particular picture
shows a Wi-Fi chip.
We've got solutions with
other networks as well.
The one we're showing here,
despite the congested Wi-Fi
environment, is the WINC1510.
It's got the TLS
and TCP/IP stacks
built in so you
don't have to think
about that in your application.
Think about it as, you send
some bytes, get some bytes.
And it all would be useless if
there was nobody to talk to.
So it's all set
up in the same way
to talk to Google IoT Cloud.
And so now you've got
this easy to design
solution with an easy to
use cloud environment,
and that's exactly what your
customers are looking for.
And it's highly secure.
So when you go
down and attack it,
you're not going to
get that private key.
So let me pass off to Zoltan.
ZOLTAN ARATO: Thanks, Kerry.
So just to reiterate,
there are two sides
of providing highly secure
end to end deployment,
a secure chip, and the cloud.
So let's talk a little bit
about the cloud side of things.
So three key challenges
we kept in mind
while building an IoT solution,
and while developing Cloud IoT.
Secure device connection.
Probably needless to
talk more about this.
That's the topic of
the presentation.
Scaling on demand, meaning
you start with a prototype,
you deploy 10, 20, 100 devices.
And when you feel
like it's time,
you can easily go to a million.
And actionable insights.
So these devices
generate lots of data,
and you have to look
behind that data.
What's behind that data?
What kind of analytics you
can get out of that data,
what you read out of that data.
And so, these are the principles
we kept in mind while designing
Google Cloud IoT.
So this is just an
overview of Cloud IoT Core
and the whole
ecosystem around it.
Cloud IoT Core is our solution
for connecting devices,
managing them,
ingesting device data,
and sending configuration
and device updates to them.
So you can see our edge solution
here, we just announced it.
I'm not going to talk about it,
we don't have time for that.
But please check it out
online, it's really cool.
What you can see here is,
we have these end devices,
and then our edge solution,
and then the cloud
side of things, Cloud IoT Core.
It's directly
integrated with Pub/Sub,
our solution to channel
messages into our Cloud service
and other cloud services.
So like Cloud
Functions or Dataflow,
and then to store them in
one of our storage solutions,
or visualize them using
Datalab or Data Studio.
The network.
Very important to talk
about one of our strengths
is our network.
When it comes to an IoT
deployment, latency is crucial.
So Google is actually
the only non ISP
company owning submarine fiber.
And this network that
we own enables us
to provide super low latencies.
And you get this out
of the box if you
start using Cloud IoT Core.
Just a little bit more
details about Cloud IoT Core.
There are two main components.
Protocol bridge.
MQTT and HTTP bridges,
that's where devices connect.
That's where they can send
data and receive configurations
or commands.
It's super scalable, and it's
directly connected to Pub/Sub.
And, of course, the
scaling is automatic.
The Device Manager is for
managing the devices, managing
configurations, access control.
And there is a nice UI as well
for managing your devices.
But also, API
support is available.
So security.
Let's talk about
the authentication
because this is really
unique in our solution.
So we are using a JWT
based authentication.
The device has the private key.
It signs a JWT token
using its private key,
and overloads the password field
of the MQTT connect message
with this JWT token.
So essentially what
happens is that we
are providing mutual
authentication
without the well known TLS
mutual authentication protocol.
Now, of course, this requires
the corresponding public key
to be registered in the cloud.
So that has to happen before the
device can authenticate itself
with the cloud.
And so, once again, this is
unique because you essentially
get TLS mutual
authentication functionality
without having to have the
full TLS stack on your device.
So that can save
resources on your devices,
which is a usual problem
in case of resource
constrained devices.
All right.
So let's take a look at
the basic provisioning
flow, how you register devices.
So the provisioner,
whoever the provisioner is,
creates a key pair, stores
the private key in the device,
and then registers the
public key together
with the device ID in the cloud.
And then the device can
connect by signing a JWT using
its private key to the cloud.
Now, this looks simple
and good, but this is not
the most secure solution.
And that's because the key pairs
are generated using software.
And we just discussed
that using a secure chip
is more like a highly secure
solution, more secure solution.
So this is how the flow looks
like using the secure chip.
So the difference is
really that the secure chip
is added to your device.
It already contains
the public keys.
And whoever the OEM is, whoever
manufactures the devices,
receives the public
key as a file,
and can run a script to
register these devices.
And then it's the same
process when it comes
to the connection of devices.
Now, this is highly secure.
It's simple.
It all looks good.
But is this enough?
No.
So there are still
challenges here.
So there are two main
areas of challenges.
One is key management.
How do you secure the
private keys in case
you do not use a secure chip?
Because not everyone
is using a secure chip.
But even if you
use a secure chip,
how do you transfer the public
keys from the secure element
provider, like
Microchip, to the OEM,
to the device manufacturer.
The other big area of
challenges is device management.
How do you map the public keys
to projects or registries?
So how do you define the
location of your device
in your cloud project?
And these decisions
have to be made
at the time of manufacturing.
So overall, it's
a complex project.
And to tackle these
two problem spaces,
we are happy to
introduce Cloud IoT
Provisioning, a new
service, available as part
of an early access program.
So you can apply for it.
And it's essentially
an interface
connecting secure
element providers
and device manufacturers, OEMs.
So secure element providers
can upload public key data
into the cloud directly.
And this public
key data together
with the corresponding
secure element
ID is available for the
device manufacturers.
So the device manufacturers
can create and assign
targets for these
secure elements.
And, probably most
importantly, it
provides a way to create generic
devices, devices for which you
don't need to set the target
information, the project
registry information, at
the time of manufacturing.
They can download
this configuration
as part of the first boot.
So let's see a
demonstration of this.
All right, this is the Cloud
IoT Provisioning early version
interface.
As I mentioned, there
are two personas here,
the SE manufacturer, so the
secure element provider,
and the OEM.
And in this case, the
secure element data
is already uploaded.
So I'm going to use this as an
OEM, as a device manufacturer.
I'm going to claim
elements based on reel ID.
So a reel is a set of
these secure chips.
And I already have
an ID prepared here.
So I have claimed
these elements.
So you can see that these
secure chips are now listed,
and I can assign
them to a target.
But before I do that, let
me open the console here.
So this is Cloud IoT Core.
If all goes well, I have
a registry prepared here.
And you can see that there
is only one device in it.
This one.
Now I go back to the
Provisioning service,
and I'm going to assign these
devices, these secure elements,
to a target.
What is the target?
The target is essentially
a project ID, region,
and the registry ID.
I have one prepared
here, so let's do it.
All right, so now
what happened is
that I have added these
devices to the project.
And we can see the
devices are here.
So one part that I
didn't demonstrate
is that, as I
mentioned, these devices
can download their configuration
as part of the first boot.
I cannot demonstrate
that right now,
but that's also part
of the solution.
Cool.
So with that, I would
like to invite Lucio
to the stage who is going
to show us another demo.
LUCIO DI JASIO:
Thank you, Zollie.
So I hope you can hear me.
Lucio di Jasio.
I work for Microchip technology.
And I have to say, I love
software, don't get me wrong.
But I like when software really
starts touching hardware.
Then the fun begins for me.
So I'm here.
And since we are
at Google Next, I
do the Google thing,
which is I'm going
to show you something new.
It's going to be a sneak
peek into a product
that Microchip is
preparing for this fall.
And you get the privilege,
actually, to see it in action.
There's going to be a
live demo in front of you.
So this is a concept that
we've been working on
to demonstrate practically
the things that Zollie
and Kerry have been describing
in the presentation before.
And so, I'm going to
literally actually show you
a little board.
Here's the thing.
It's one inch by two
and a half or so.
And this is a concept
that we came up with
to try and demonstrate
practically the effectiveness
of a secure element,
and how actually ideal
the Google Cloud solution,
the use of the JWT,
is for bringing
secure cloud solutions
even to the smallest devices
in the pyramid of the embedded
controlled world.
So we want to take a secure
solution to the cloud down
to an 8-bit device.
So I'll show you.
Maybe you can actually see
it on the screen better.
It's quite small, so I
hope you can figure it out.
I'll use a pointer here.
And you'll see there's
a debugger here.
This is a full development
system, if you want,
inside an engagement board.
And this is a complete system.
Here you have the
smart of the solution.
This is a small
microcontroller, just an 8-bit.
As Kerry said, Microchip
makes, ships 2 billion units
of these chips every year.
This is not a cumulative number.
Every year, we ship
2 billion of them.
And this is what most bare
metal embedded control solutions
are made of out
there in industrial,
in automotive, in
all the fields.
So this small 8-bit
micro now is connected
to the secure element.
And I'm sorry, Kerry.
Your slide had the secure
element as big as my chip,
but actually, it is the
smallest thing on this board.
The secure element is smaller
than a temperature sensor,
actually.
Speaking of Room 12, was it?
12?
So 23.
So this is a temperature sensor.
This is a secure
element with all
the crypto elliptic-curve
security management
and all the features
built in there.
And this is a light sensor, for
example, that we added here.
And also here you see
a typical radio module.
This is the WINC1510.
It's one of Microchip's
many wireless solutions.
So all this connected
on this board.
And I want you to notice
also, this connector here,
these pins here.
And this is where
you can actually
plug in-- this is a micro bus.
So you can pick and choose
between 450 additional sensors
readily off the menu, literally.
And pick and choose, and
try to quickly prototype
whatever your solution is.
So maybe it's not just the
temperature sensor in Room 12.
Maybe there's also a
humidity sensor and pressure
sensor and an altimeter
and whatever you want.
So I will actually
demonstrate how
this board works, making
it connect quickly
to the Google Cloud.
And so, we designed not
only just the board.
That's easy, that comes fast.
We designed a
complete experience
around this on how we can
get a user quickly engaged
with the Google Cloud.
And so, what I will do now
is I will actually power
up this board, and that
should blink some LEDs.
That's what you expect, huh?
Is that pretty?
I blink these four LEDs.
Yeah, that's what we
do in embedded control,
we blink a lot of LEDs.
So one thing you might
want to know is that--
sorry.
Let me get this off here.
And this is the good part of
doing the live demo, right?
So in the experience,
what you will see now
is the thing that
this board actually
behaves as a hard drive.
So my PC, without
installing anything,
recognizes this as if it was
a flash stick, basically.
There is really no
storage on the device.
And so, if I can change
to Kerry's desktop,
and if you can actually
visualize that on the screen--
thank you.
So you will see that this board
appears on Zollie's laptop
as a hard drive
called Curiosity.
So hopefully it will
pique your curiosity,
and you will want to
check inside this drive.
And inside this drive--
again, I didn't
install any software.
I don't need special
drivers for this--
you will see there is a
bunch of interesting files.
They're not real files.
One of them is
called Click Me, so I
hope you will be tempted to
press on the Click Me one.
And from there, you will
actually see that by default,
because it was a .htm file,
whatever operating system you
have, a Mac, a PC,
or even a Linux box,
you will see it immediately
open the default browser.
And the browser will
open up on the page that
is a special landing page
that we prepared, a sandbox.
It's part of a sandbox account.
But this landing page
contains the real experience,
and has been prepared for
us by Google, and actually,
in particular, by
Leverage, a partner that
has been working with
us and with Google
to create this ideal experience.
So as you can see,
actually, you can
see that the device
in particular,
the secure element-- and
this is the unique identifier
of that secure element.
And so, we landed
now on this page.
This is a dynamic page.
And as luck wants,
I'll show you now
how this page
actually changes when
we do connect to the cloud.
And I have my browser
open right here.
This is quite a
hard test because we
tested this, obviously, in
the room without all of you
with your phones on and without
the Wi-Fi hotspots present.
So there is 120 more than
when we tested this first.
Hopefully I will get
it to actually connect
to the right
hotspot and I'll get
to show you some real data
streaming on the board.
And no, it's not today.
So in the last minute?
Tough luck.
I think we'll have
to call it a day.
So ideally, basically you
would see the blue LED connect
directly to the correct hotspot
that is actually sitting here,
and then a green LED turning
on as soon as the connection
with Wi-Fi is established.
Then a connection to the
MQTT broker of Google
will happen immediately.
And then after that, you will
see the board immediately
blinking a yellow LED.
The sequence of
color, if you notice,
is the Google color sequence.
And then the yellow
LED actually represents
each packet of data that is
being published to MQTT broker.
And then when that
successfully happens,
as we will not have
the luck to see today,
you will actually see on your
screens, on your browser,
you will see the blue line
connecting all the way through.
And the page,
actually dynamically,
instantaneously will show you
the graph with the two sensors'
data.
So the temperature and the
light sensor on this board.
And it will be immediately
animated on your screen.
How good would this be if
it was just a board and just
this part of the experience?
You know, the goal
here is not only
to give you a five or sub 30
seconds, that's what we claim,
experience and connection
to the Google Cloud.
But after that, you will
want to change the sensors
and apply your own
specific sensor.
So you will want to write your
own firmware inside the board,
inside the microcontroller
on this board.
And just for you, if
you're not familiar
with this particular
brand of products,
you might have heard
that the AVR that
is the microcontroller
shown here
is the one that is
inside the Arduinos.
So most students today coming
out of schools and university
and out of--
the hobbyists community are
very familiar with that.
And so, they will
want to play with it.
And so, professional and
nonprofessional developers
actually will find a
solution that we prepared
for them, which is,
as Kerry mentioned
before, we have a rapid
development toolset that
is composed of two pieces
of software, MCC and START.
One for the PIC devices and
one for the AVR devices.
And with those, literally
with a click of the mouse
you will be able to see--
let me just scroll
to the correct page.
So this is START
for the AVR devices.
And here you see
the blocks composing
the project that
is actually running
on this board in
this very moment.
And this is available
in your browser.
So you will do all
your reconfiguration
of the device on the fly,
clicking on each block,
changing the configuration.
You see the
cryptoauthentication block.
That's what controls the ECC608.
So all the software is wrapped
in there and templated by that.
And so, the MQTT IoT block
that you see there in blue
is the block that wraps
the entire communication
infrastructure, everything that
is needed to access the WINC
device, the Wi-Fi chip.
And the part on the left where
you see scheduler, ADC user,
the embedded developers among
you will recognize those names.
Those are the acronyms of
the individual peripherals
inside the chip.
And so, again, you can go there
and configure them, and select
them, and make them read
temperature, read humidity,
read whatever other
entity you want to read.
And so, you can create
a complete solution
with a few clicks of your mouse.
And then hit up
there Export Project,
and just hit the Build
button on your [? ID. ?]
And with this, I will give
back to the mic to Zollie.
ZOLTAN ARATO: Yeah, and
please stay on stage.
Just very quickly because
we are running out of time,
can we please go back
to the presentation?
Thank you.
So just a very quick summary
of the whole presentation.
So as I said,
there are two sides
of providing end-to-end
security, hardware,
software cloud.
Strong IoT security
uses a secure chip.
And then ease of design
with the turnkey MCU.
So you've seen that 8-bit
MCU which is brand new.
And then when it comes to the
cloud, simple connection which
we were unfortunately
unable to demonstrate.
But it is simple, believe me.
I saw it.
And built in, so built
into these devices.
They can connect to
the cloud and scale.
So Cloud IoT provides
scaling on demand and also
actionable insights using
the other Google Cloud tools
and services.
And with that, we would like
to conclude our presentation.
Thanks for attending.
KERRY MALETSKY: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]